Conor McGregor's most recent Instagram
post he just put this up an hour ago
this dude is always showing [__] man why
is he looking like that bro how would
you describe this for the uh for the
audio listeners okay picture Conor
McGregor right
now picture being forehead to forehead
with Conor McGregor and he's got a big
old smile okay picture him like almost
cradling you a little bit
in his arms he's shirtless he's
pantsless and uh he's pedaling showing
[__]
that's how I describe it the Bulge is
also gyrating from side to side yeah
with the movement of his legs and then
he periodically Winks at you yeah
anyways I thought you'd enjoy that oh
yeah no I appreciate that man yeah no
problem